[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est pour parler de notre
séminaire d'intégration qui s'est passé
durant juillet pour février désolé au
centre jacques pési séminaire
d'intégration qui veut dire qu'on a
rencontré des autres missions la parler
avec d'autres jeunes comme nous ils
aiment cdj côté c'est avec eux qu'on va
travailler tout en étant premier atelier
avec un jeu qui s'appelle monsieur
ethève nous a tout simplement pris un
petit peu à prendre la parole
vous avez des astuces des conseils pour
pouvoir parler en public
moi s'exprimer correctement tu t'en vas
continuer sur un autre atelier une
conduite de projets donc on a appris
tout simplement en dix points
comment comment conduire à un projet
convenablement avec qui avec qui se
mettent dans des partenariats etc
[Musique]
donc on a décidé cette année de la mise
en place d'un séminaire d'intégration à
destination des collégiens pas des
jeunes c'est le troisième et le
quatrième
pourquoi parce que c'est vrai que dans
au niveau de la nacelle il est
indispensable de faire ce séminaire
justement pour permettre une cohésion de
groupe en pour les jeunes donc à partir
de là avec les thématiques donc on va
travailler sur un plan administratif
pour mettre en place ces projets avec
des partenaires mais il ya des idées
très intéressant qu'il ya une dizaine de
projets qui ont été décidées bien sûr
comme les quatrièmes été prise ont donc
les quatrièmes ils pourront prendre le
relais pour l'année prochaine et faire
une continuité des actions
[Musique]